the transcriptomics section is designed
in a way that you can start using the
pipeline very quickly right after you
upload the data you can always go to
this question mark and see guidance on
how to use this section in this little
pop-up but let me show you quickly how
to upload the data and start your
pipeline under the Advanced Options you
will see that you have a few a few types
of dropdowns that help you determine
what kind of data you're uploading so
you have a model genome with a GTF file
with an annotation file you might have a
genome that you want to upload yourself
and you might want to upload an
annotated genome that is not contained
in our section under organism over here
right now I'm going to use a human
genome so I'm going to select the human
genome over here single and repair and
you typically know from the data whether
this is the P or parent or single ends
and you can select a number of formats
over here additional formats are
available but we have not put them as
defaults under this drop-down now you
can upload your flats you can either
upload your files from the computer or
use links HTTP or FTP links as well as
in svl which is a reference to link to
the files that are already on the server
let me upload a few example files so you
can see that they will upload and I can
also cancel the upload and then once
they are done or as they are uploading I
can define the groups and I can make a
number of groups here or I can cancel
this option all together if I don't want
to separate the files into any groups
now I'm ready to start by clicking on
the start button I will see a pop-up
that explains what this section does
again I can navigate through these
explanations over here and once I click
OK I now selected the pipeline to be
started so
each section contains a number of
options I can read about the section by
clicking on the section title I can also
select buttons that are highlighted by
this yellow and dark color over here so
for example in this case I will have
some formats that I can choose from and
and that's how you can just navigate
through these different sections and
understand what's going on again if you
have any questions you can go through
this popup over here located on your
bottom right corner
so the typical pipeline will include
mapping and I'm going to use top hat and
then we can use cufflinks and to do
isoform construction and then we can use
low tide to words or we can cancel we
can do cuff merge and that will merge
together several couplings assemblies
now if you made a mistake and you want
to go back you just right-click on that
button and that will allow you to jump
to the previous step so you can see ID
selected this you can select it again
and I'm going to map it on transcripts
using bow tied to now what I want to do
is create an expression level table and
that aligns everything and you can read
there's a publication over here so our
sum expression table I'm going to use
that and I sometimes want to do an X on
table in this case I'm not going to do
that so I'm just going to click end and
in the end there's another area where
you can read a little bit more it
reminds you to press on the one pipeline
button after you're done it also
explains what kind of output files
you're expected to get in the end so I'm
going to save this pipeline I'm going to
name it
save it and you can notice here I have
to click the run pipeline button don't
forget to do this but just let's go and
look over here you can see the pipeline
that I've created and now I can close
this one pipeline button so once I click
the run pipeline button I will be
automatically redirected to this screen
you can see that the pipeline has
started and you can also see that
there's no output files for now and you
can see the graph again so if I go to my
pipelines you will actually see that the
RNA seat is processing it now and once
it will be complete I will be able to
see more details download a report and
navigate to the download section